[Music]
in 1963 a 21 year old physicist named
Stephen Hawking was diagnosed with a
rare neuromuscular disorder called
amyotrophic lateral sclerosis or ALS
gradually he lost the ability to walk
use his hands move his face and even
swallow but throughout it all he
retained his incredible intellect and in
the more than 50 years that followed
Hawking became one of history's most
accomplished and famous physicists
however his condition went uncured and
he passed away in 2018 at the age of 76
decades after his diagnosis ALS still
ranks as one of the most complex
mysterious and devastating diseases to
affect humankind also called motor
neuron disease and Lou Gehrig's disease
ALS affects about two out of every
100,000 people worldwide when a person
has ALS their motor neurons the cells
responsible for all voluntary muscle
control in the body lose function and
die no one knows exactly why or how
these cells died and that's part of what
makes ALS so hard to treat in about 90%
of cases the disease arises suddenly
with no apparent cause the remaining 10%
of cases are hereditary where a mother
or father with ALS passes on a mutated
gene to their child the symptoms
typically first appear after age 40 but
in some rare cases like Hawking's ALS
starts earlier in life Hawking's case
was also a medical marvel because of how
long he lived with ALS after diagnosis
most people with the disease live
between two to five years before ALS
leads to respiratory problems that
usually cause death what wasn't unusual
in Hawking's case was that his ability
to learn think and perceive with his
senses remained intact most people with
ALS do not experience impaired cognition
with so much at stake for the 120,000
people who were diagnosed with ALS
annually curing the disease has become
one of our most important scientific and
medical challenges despite the many
unknowns we do have some insight into
how ALS impacts the neuromuscular system
ALS affects two types of nerve cells
called the upper and lower motor neurons
in a healthy body the upper motor
neurons which sit in the brains cortex
transmit messages from the brain to the
lower motor neurons situated in the
spinal cord those neurons then transmit
the message into muscle fibers which
contract or relax in response resulting
in motion every voluntary move we make
occurs because of messages transmitted
along this pathway but when motor
neurons degenerate in ALS their ability
to transfer messages is disrupted and
that vital signaling system is thrown
into chaos without their regular cues
the muscles waste away precisely what
makes the motor neurons degenerate is
the prevailing mystery of ALS in
hereditary cases parents pass genetic
mutations on to their children
even then ALS involves multiple genes
with multiple possible impacts on motor
neurons making the precise triggers hard
to pinpoint when als arises sporadically
the list of possible causes grows toxins
viruses lifestyle or other environmental
factors may all play roles and because
there are so many elements involved
there's currently no single test that
can determine whether someone has ALS
nevertheless our hypotheses on the
causes are developing one prevailing
idea is that certain proteins inside the
motor neurons aren't folding correctly
and are instead forming clumps the miss
folded proteins and clumps may spread
from cell to cell this could be clogging
up normal cellular processes like energy
and protein production which keep cells
alive we've also learned that along with
motor neurons and muscle fibers ALS
could involve
other cell types ALS patients tip
we have inflammation in their brains and
spinal cords defective immune cells may
also play a role in killing motor
neurons and ALS seems to change the
behavior of specific cells that provide
support for neurons these factors
highlight the disease's complexity but
they may also give us a fuller
understanding of how it works
opening up new avenues for treatment and
while that may be gradual we're making
progress all the time we're currently
developing new drugs new stem cell
therapies to repair damaged cells and
new gene therapies to slow the
advancement of the disease with our
growing arsenal of knowledge we look
forward to discoveries that can change
the future for people living with ALS
[Music]